>> THINGS TO COVID, HARVARD IS
OFFERING ONLINE CLASSES TO
STUDENTS BUT THE SAME PRICE OF
THE OLD AT 50 GRAND.
DOES THAT MATTER?
AFTER ALL, A HARVARD EDUCATION
ISN’T FOR THE EDUCATION, IT’S
FOR THE NAME.
HARVARD IS THE ULTIMATE VIRTUE
SIGNAL FOR THE ELITE SELLING
AUTHORITY.
SOEVER YOU GO AROUND THE
CORNERS, YOU FIND THESE CLOWNS
ALWAYS TRYING TO ACT CASUAL WHEN
THEY DROP HARVARD INTO A
CONVERSATION AND SEEING HOW
OVERPRICED AND OVERVALUED
CONVERSATION LEADS TO
OVERBEARING TRIPS WHO WERE
BOW TIES BUT STILL CAN’T TIE
THEM.
BUT THIS IS WHERE COVID HELPS
BECAUSE ONLINE CLASSES WILL MAKE
COLLEGE WAY BETTER FOR PARENTS,
WE WILL BE EASY TO SEE HOW
PROFESSORS ARE INDOCTRINATED ARE
INDOCTRINATING NOW.
THE PARENT CAN SEE WHAT GARBAGE
IS BEING LADLED INTO THEIR
OFFSPRINGS’ GOALS RIGHT FROM
THEIR VERY LAPTOP.
WILL SOON REALIZE THAT IT IS
VOCATIONAL TRADING FOR ANY IDIOT
IS EXPOSED FOR WHAT IT IS, A
SCAM.
TWO ADMINISTRATORS WHO BALLOON
COSTS FROM KINDERGARTEN TO GRAD
SCHOOL.
THAT IS THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
DOESN’T MAKE PEOPLE SMARTER, IT
MAKES SOME PEOPLE RICHER AND
OTHERS POOR.
IN TUITIONS ARE AT AN ALL-TIME
HIGH BUT CARRY OUT INTELLIGENCE
IS AT AN ALL-TIME LOW, SO I SAY
GO ONLINE, THE BEST PART, NO WE
WEIRD COLLEGE ROOMMATES IN LESS
COUNTS MOM AND DAD.
SO DANA, I HAVE A THEORY THAT I
THINK YOU WILL LIKE.
ONCE WE COMBINE ONLINE COURSES
WITH ACTUAL TALENTED PERFORMERS,
MEANS ACADEMIA MIMICKED PALATINE
WHICH BASICALLY TOOK THE GYM OUT
OF THE GYM AND BROUGHT IT ONLINE
AND THEN HIRED EXTREMELY
CHARISMATIC TALENTED PERFORMERS
TO EXERCISE, IT BECOMES
IRRELEVANT.
THEY APPLY THAT MODEL TO COLLEGE
AND PUT IT ON YOUTUBE, WHO NEEDS
HARVARD?
>> I TOTALLY AGREE, IT HAS BEEN
CHANGED, LOOK AT THE PLACE LIKE
PURDUE UNIVERSITY.
IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS, HAVE
NOT RAISE TUITION AT ALL, THEIR
GRADUATES DO VERY WELL,
CONNECTIONS TO EMPLOYERS THAT
HELP PAY FOR TUITION FOR LOWER
INCOME STUDENTS IN THE EDUCATION
IS SUPERB.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A KID, I
WANTED GUESS JEANS SO BADLY ON
MY MOM AND DAD WERE LIKE NO,
LEVI’S WILL DO JUST FINE FOR YOU
AND I WAS SOBER SO UPSET.
THESE WERE EXCELLENT GENES AND
THAT’S WHAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
START TO FIND OUT THAT PART OF
THE THING OF GOING TO COLLEGE IS
THE EXPERIENCE, NOT JUST GOING
TO CLASS THEM IT’S TO MEET
PEOPLE, HANG OUT, GET TO GO TO
PARTIES AND ALL THAT STUFF, HOW
IN THE WORLD HARVARD COULD NOT
HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW TO LOWER
THE TUITION PRICE AND THE
SITUATION MAKES ME THINK THAT
THEY DON’T EVEN WANT TO.
THEY TRY TO GET THE PPP LOANS AS
WELL.
SO I THINK EDUCATION IS FOREVER
CHANGED AND I DO HOPE THAT SOME
NEW INSTITUTIONS ARE BUILT INTO
THIS.
WHAT ABOUT SOMEONE WHO HAD THAT
GREAT PROGRAM TO OFFER PEOPLE
MONEY IF THEY DIDN’T GO TO
COLLEGE BUT WHAT ABOUT SOMETHING
MORE STRUCTURED AND A NEW
INSTITUTION THAT PEOPLE COULD
LOOK THROUGH AND WE SHOULD ALL
JUST GO FOR IT.
>> DANA BROUGHT UP THE POINT
ABOUT PEOPLE GO TO COLLEGE
BECAUSE FOR THE EXPERIENCE, I
BELIEVE THAT I KNOW YOU DISAGREE
THAT THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE WAS
COMPLETELY OVERRATED BUT I’M
SURE YOU FEEL DIFFERENTLY.
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT YOU DID IN
COLLEGE, BUT I THOUGHT THE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE WAS PRETTY
HELPFUL.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE HARDEST PART
ABOUT HARVARD IS GETTING INTO
HARVARD.
ONCE YOU ARE INTO HARVARD, IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET BELOW A B.
WHAT DID THEY SAY, HALF OF LIFE
IS JUST SHOWING OUT?
SAME WITH HARVARD BUT NOW YOU
DON’T HAVE TO SHOW UP SO IT’S
LIKE THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
CAMBRIDGE CAMPUS, SO WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO SOMEHOW QUANTIFIES
THE HARVARD EXPERIENCE AND THEN
LOP THAT COST OFF OF THE TUITION
AND I DON’T SEE WHY PEOPLE
AREN’T BURNING UP THE TRUSTEE’S
PHONES RIGHT NOW WITH THAT VERY
IDEA BECAUSE IF YOU ARE HARVARD,
YOU DON’T WANT TO OPEN BECAUSE
OF LITIGATION OR BECAUSE SOME OF
THE PROFESSORS ARE 65 AND OVER
AND DON’T WANT TO SIT IN THE
CLASSROOM WITH A BUNCH OF YOUNG
CARRIERS SO IN THAT CASE, SLAP
ON THE MASS, CRACK THE WINDOW
AND SEPARATE THE DESKS 6 FEET OR
DO WHAT EVERYONE LOVES, HOLD
CLASSES OUTSIDE.
IN THE QUAD, ON THE FOOTBALL
FIELD, I’M SURE GAIL IS DOING
THAT.
>> I THINK THEY ARE CHANGING
THEIR NAME.
IT’S GOING TO BE GREAT FOR
PARENTS BECAUSE THEY MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SEE EXACTLY WHAT IS
BEING TAUGHT, RIGHT?
>> I’M NOT SURE I’D UNDERSTAND,
YOU GET INTO SOME OF THESE MORE
THEORETICAL CLASSES, I DIDN’T
UNDERSTAND A WORD, BUT TO YOUR
POINT, HERE IS WHERE I COME
DOWN.
I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, HARVARD IS
A PRIVATE INSTITUTION.
YOU GET INTO HARVARD AND YOU
DON’T WANT TO GO, DON’T ENROLL,
DON’T PAY THE PRICE, YOU CAN
MAKE THAT CALL.
I JUST DON’T THINK MANY PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO MAKE THAT CALL IN A
VERY PRACTICAL LEVEL.
MOST PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IT IS NOT
JUST ABOUT THE CREDENTIAL WHICH
IS VERY IMPRESSIVE, HARVARD
EDUCATION BUT IT’S ABOUT
ASSOCIATING WITH OTHER VERY
SMART PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
SOMEWHERE IN LIFE, A VERY SELECT
GROUP OF PEOPLE AND EVEN IF THEY
AREN’T ABLE TO COME TOGETHER
INITIALLY BECAUSE OF THE COVID
VIRUS SITUATION, THAT DOESN’T
MEAN THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GET
BACK TOGETHER COME 2021 AND
BEYOND.
THE THING THAT EYE OF COURSE I’M
REACTING TO THEM TODAY IS THE
PRESIDENT SAYING EVERYBODY’S GOT
TO HAVE SCHOOLS OPEN IN THE FALL
AND OF COURSE, NOT ONLY THE
PROFESSORS, IT’S THE TEACHERS AT
THE ELEMENTARY AND HIGH SCHOOLS
WHO SAY THEY WORRY FOR
THEMSELVES, PARENTS WHO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU FIND
IT HARD TO HAVE SOCIAL
DISTANCING ON A SCHOOL BUS MY
REAL ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH AND INSTEAD OF MAKING IT
POLITICAL, I THINK WE SHOULD
REALLY TALK ABOUT HOW CAN WE GET
SCHOOLS TO WORK THIS FALL?
>> I DON’T THINK ANYBODY MADE IT
POLITICAL, THAT’S ACTUALLY
MAKING A STATEMENT, POLITICIZING
IS SAYING YOU DIDN’T THINK ABOUT
THE HEALTH PROBLEMS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE HEALTH
PROBLEM.
I THINK PARENTS WILL BE RELIEVED
THAT THEIR KIDS ARE GOING BACK
TO SCHOOL.
I WAS A PARENT, I’D WANT THEM
OUT OF THE HOUSE.
EMILY, LAST WORD TO YOU.
>> YOU DON’T WANT TO GET SICK.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT,
THANK YOU.
>> THIS DOESN’T SURPRISE ME AT
ALL.
REMEMBER WHEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HIKED TUITION AND IT
BECAME KNOWN THAT 85% WAS
BECAUSE OF PENSIONS?
THAT IS AN ASSOCIATION WITH THE
EXCLUSIVITY BUT ALSO JUST BAD
MATH.
HARVARD HAS THE LARGEST
ENDOWMENT IN THE COUNTRY, WAS
ALMOST 41 BILLION AND YET THEY
PAY OUT 70% OF THEIR STUDENT
BODY FROM FINANCIAL AID IN SOME
WAY, SO IT MAKES ALL THE SENSE
TO ME THAT THEY WOULDN’T LOWER
COSTS EVEN IF THERE IS NO
OPERATING OVERHEAD ANYMORE OF
COURSE BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO PAY
ALL THE BILLS.
THE PROFESSORSHIPS, ALL OF THEIR